And now, as we are in the throes
of election season,
it is time for another
installment of Voter Voices.
(cheering and applause)
This incredibly important,
classic segment
that we've only actually done
one other time.
This is what we hear
from a niche group of voters
who could sway
this very close election.
Tonight's group is Furries.
The Facebook page Furries for
Trump is titillating voters
with its sexy rabbit drawings.
Ah!
Just ruined Space Jam for me.
(laughter)
The hashtag #FurriesForHillary
has been used
a whopping five times.
So here to give us a perspective
of an undecided Furry
is Connor Coop,
aka Dreamhorse Sweetnipple.
♪ ♪
(cheering and applause)
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you for having me, Chris.
Now, we Furries may seem
a little out there, um.
But we're just like you.
We are lawyers.
We are teachers.
We're doctors.
Um, I'm an unlicensed
gynecologist, for instance.
HARDWICK:
Oh.
We're normal Americans,
uh, who just happen to derive
sexual gratification
cranking it to crude sketches
of raccoon people
with arm-length dongs.
Now, first of all, you're
actually not very furry.
-Do not velour-shame me.
-HARDWICK: Okay.
I am sorry, Connor.
I am very sorry.
Uh, please. Call me, uh,
Dreamhorse Sweetnipple
when I'm in my true skin.
HARDWICK:
All right, Mr. Sweetnipple.
It's actually, uh, sorry.
-It is actually
Dr. Sweetnipple. -Okay.
I didn't spend six years
getting my nipples sweetened
in medical school to be called
Mister on a basic cable program.
All right, Dr.,
Dr. Sweetnipple-- okay, okay.
So politically,
where are you right now?
Why are you undecided?
(neighs like a horse)
HARDWICK:
Whoa!
-I get a little worked up.
-Whoa, boy.
Am I presenting to the right?
Am I presenting?
-Yeah, you're presenting.
-It's right in my face.
HARDWICK;
You're presenting very well.
And there-there's something
about you squatting
makes it creepier--
I don't know what it...
(laughter)
I was told this would be
a relatively safe space.
Tom,
you told me at the convention
this was gonna be a safe space.
On-Once you're here,
it's... you're fair game.
-You're in the arena.
-Fair enough.
Speaking of game, uh,
part of me is drawn to Trump
'cause of his tax policy.
Um, I would love to be able
to write off
my dry cleaning expenses
every year.
Um, I do spend a lot of money
on-on dry cleaning.
HARDWICK:
Like how much?
Like $45,000 to $50,000
every year.
HARDWICK:
Oh, okay, yeah, that's... Why?
I jizz in this thing
all the time is why.
-HARDWICK; Oh, I see, okay.
-It's full of jizz.
Um... (neighs) On the other
hand, though,
I am- I am drawn to Hillary's
maternity leave policy.
HARDWICK:
Okay.
Uh, because I'm a bad unicorn,
uh, who needs to be spanked
by his mommy.
HARDWICK:
Well, I don't think that's...
I don't think that's what the
plan is actually set up for.
Well, actually, if you go
through her Web site, the...
HARDWICK:
Whoa!
Oh, my God.
-Come on!
-CAMPBELL: Oh!
-I am so s... -Wow. -You just
knocked over the ashes
-of Lucille Ball. We keep
that urn here... -Oh, no.
-for good luck. This was
the I Love Lucy stage, and...
-I'm very sorry. -Granted,
it was probably a bad idea
to keep it there next to your
rainbow (bleep), but...
-Come on. -Wow.
-I'm really sorry.
-Terrible.
-All right, you know what,
thank you for being here.
You did a good job.
Do you want to, uh, come get...
come get an apple?
-Yes, please, yeah.
-You want some apple?
-(neighs)
-Here you go.
-Open palm-- I will bite you.
-Oh, okay, all right,
all right, there you go,
there you go. Good, good.
-Thank you.
-Good, Sweetnipple.
-That's Dr. Dreamhorse
Sweetnipple, everyone. -♪ ♪
I'm glad we give people a voice
on this show, uh...
For-for a unicorn, that was
actually kind of average-sized.
You better watch yourself--
Voldemort sucked his (bleep)
to stay alive.
He's... he's more of a...
he's more of a duocorn.
He is kind of a duocorn,
you're right.